ما هو ردك على هذه الأخبار
حول ما كان يقوله لبوب وودوارد
في السابع من فبراير إنه أمر مثير للاشمئزاز لقد
علمنا هذا في اليوم الذي قتل فيه مائة
ألف أمريكي
وكان يعلم
هذا وأدرك أنه كان قد أغلق
الهاتف للتو عندما فعل ذلك  في المقابلة الأولى
مع وودوارد
أنه خرج للتو من الهاتف مع xi
jinping حيث أشاد بـ xi jinping
بشأن الشفافية
وهذا لا يدعو
للقلق وسيختفي مثل المعجزة
جيدًا بالطريقة التي شرحها الرئيس ترامب
وقال هذا أه
إلى Woodward في التاسع عشر من مارس ، إذا
كنت تسمع ،
كنت أرغب دائمًا في تشغيلها ، ما زلت
أحب تشغيلها ،
نعم سيدي ، لأنني لا أريد أن أخلق
حالة من الذعر ، فقد قال شيئًا
مشابهًا بعد ظهر هذا اليوم ، قال إنه لا
يريد ذلك  خلق حالة من الذعر لهذا
السبب قلل من شأنها ، قال إن القيادة
تتعلق
بالثقة ، وهذا هو السبب في أننا لا
نثق في قيادته ،
مما تسبب في وفاة الناس وما
فعله طوال الوقت
هو اعترف  أن تتنفسه
في الهواء ولن يرتدي القناع
الذي يتحدث عنه من السخف أن يرتدي
القناع ما الذي تحتاجه للتباعد الاجتماعي
لسبب وجود أي من هذه القواعد كان الأمر كله
يتعلق بالتأكد من عدم وجود سوق
الأسهم  نلاحظ
أن صديقه الثري لم يخسر أي
أموال وأنه يمكن أن يقول
أنه في الواقع أي شيء حدث
لا علاقة له
به ، لوح بعلم أبيض مشى بعيدًا ،
لم يفعل شيئًا فظيعًا.
حول ما لم يفعله وهو
شبه إجرامي